quando eu tinha 10 anos
eu tive minha primeira paixão por um
homem alto bonito forte e que usava
cueca por cima da roupa
eu me apaixonei pelo super-homem porque
o super homem tinha capacidades
extraordinárias para fazer o bem ea
justiça
então eu cresci procurando pessoas que
tivessem capacidades extraordinárias
para fazer o bem à justiça e procurando
suas cabeças e capacidades em mim mesmo
eu me formei fiz o mestrado fazer o
doutorado eu passei no concurso para
professora da faculdade de direito do
recife da universidade federal de
pernambuco eu tive um filho pedro e o
pedro foi a minha primeira grande
revolução humana porque o pedro me
ensinou que a vida nos dá capacidade
extraordinárias para fazer as coisas
mais ordinárias as coisas mais comuns
como ter um filho
vou seguir a minha vida das minhas aulas
estava na área de direitos humanos
quando uma coisa completamente nova
aconteceu
eu atravessei a rua na frente da
faculdade de direito fica a câmara
municipal estava acontecendo
a audiência pública do projeto no recife
um projeto que pretende transformar essa
paisagem nessa catástrofe urbanística
todas as pessoas que estavam lá naquele
dia tinha uma coisa em comum um brilho
nos olhos
não era nada do seu cenário era só um
brilho nos olhos uma paixão pela cidade
pela nossa história a nossa paisagem mas
essa paixão fez com que até agora a
gente conseguisse impedir a construção
daquela monstruosidade
mesmo lutando contra toda uma estrutura
do poder político e econômico em 2012
quando a gente obteve a nossa primeira
decisão judicial que impediu a reunião
da prefeitura queria aprovar o projeto
no recife
nós nunca imaginamos que chegaríamos tão
longe
mas foi nessa guerra desigual e injusta
usando apenas a arma dessa paixão que a
gente tem conseguido algumas vitórias
significativas
aí eu tive uma primeira lição que foi
muito importante para o ativismo a
importância de atravessar a rua para
fora da universidade e a importância de
ter o brilho nos olhos
é importante dizer que eu nunca planejei
ativista acontecendo eu fui me
apaixonando
os olhos foram brilhando no momento eu
me indignei porque o marco zero tarde da
área do marco zero é o principal pólo do
carnaval de recife foi privatizada pelo
governo para fazer o camarote vip não
fez um pedido de informações
indagando quanto custava cada bebida
cada salgado cada doce que era o custo
total é daquelas é daqueles serviços
como por exemplo o hair stylist e
customização de fantasia e claro
indagando também quais eram os critérios
que o governo usava para selecionar quem
tinha acesso àquele camarote qual era
lista nominal dos convidados e como
cidadão comum fazia para ter acesso
àquele camarote que era pago com
dinheiro público
nós fizemos um evento no facebook foi
quero minha vaga no camarote vip do
governo foi um sucesso milhares de
pessoas aderiram compartilharam e três
dias depois do pedido de informações
o governo cancelou camarote pouco depois
eu me integrei a luta em defesa do
maracatu rural da zona da nota da mata
em pernambuco que estava sofrendo com a
censura imposta pelo governo
fizemos uma denúncia por racismo
institucional da política de segurança
pública do estado e vencemos
depois os olhos brilhando pela praça da
independência na praça da independência
era o quartel general do frevo e esse
quartel general do frevo foi privatizado
pra virar o camarote globeleza da rede
globo
imaginem que uma praça é o símbolo da
coisa pública em mais uma praça que
ganhou o nome de praça da independência
ficar presa nesse cercadinho da rede
globo
nós fizemos um pedido de informação
ocupamos a praça ea rede globo desistiu
de montar o seu camarote na praça
esse ano quando os nossos legisladores o
ceará mais uma vez que não sabe
legislatura o povo e aprovaram uma lei
que dê novo censurava cultura popular e
arte de rua
nós decidimos que nós tínhamos que fazer
a nossa lei da cultura popular uma lei
feita pela iniciativa popular com as
nossas mãos e com a nossa história
mas por incrível que pareça nesse nessas
histórias de ativismo o maior obstáculo
que eu enfrentei não foi poder econômico
no e também não foi o poder político
institucional foi uma chinesa
eu descobri que para lutar pela cidade e
pelos espaços públicos
era preciso primeiro que eu lutasse pelo
meu direito a ter voz aos espaços
públicos já que o espaço
público costuma sem ter ditado a mulher
e nele não se aceita que a mulher tem a
voz tenha visibilidade ou tenha força
principalmente quando a voz da mulher
pudesse ser mais ouvido o mais aplaudido
do que a voz de qualquer homem ou de
algum homem sabe que isso me ensinou
ensinou a te pra nós fazemos política
nós não precisamos de nenhuma capacidade
extraordinária
a gente não precisa usar a cueca por
cima da roupa
aliás a gente nem precisa da cueca
mas se não é necessário nenhuma
capacidade extraordinária para fazer
política porque tão frequentemente a
gente delega política os políticos ea
resposta que me ver essa pergunta é por
que nos ensinaram que a política é um
compartimento da vida da gente separado
de todas as outras esferas da nossa vida
é como se fosse uma gaveta mas uma
gaveta em que a gente só guarda em cali
e coisas que não prestam
não é verdade
a política é a nossa gaveta de calcinhas
a gente usa todo dia quando a gente
aprende que a gente usa política todos
os dias
vamos tentar nos convencer de que essa
calcinha uma calcinha de bisavó
bege sem graça mas a política pode ficar
um pouco mais divertida ela pode ser um
pouco mais colorida e de preferência é
bom que ela tenha mais transparência
ela pode ser mais apimentada
mas o importante é que a política venha
o nosso jeito que ela seja confortável
na gente
a gente tem intimidade com ela a
política não exige da gente a gente
tenha capacidade extraordinária mas ela
exige intimidade ela exige envolvimento
ela exige que a gente se permita deixar
o olho brilhar pelas coisas que fazem
parte da nossa vida e principalmente que
a gente deixa um pouco da nossa do nosso
brilho onde a gente vive